hey how's it going bros my name is Pippa
but you're not here for that you're here
for the game
inside part to this game it's just
absolutely incredible it is my honor and
privilege to be playing this for you it
really is amazing okay let's just push
this down without trying to get killed
this time did I just say holy moly and
ironically that's pretty good
I just said that's pretty good
ironically - damn it it's not good eh
all right we did it did we go down here
and remember wait did I just murder a
bunch of chickens I didn't realize what
I just did
chickens chickens are you okay chickens
I'm so sorry
whoa I made a hole in the ground that's
what I did okay thank God the chickens
didn't die they're not chickens they
were Birds well whatever this game is so
immersive I hope you're watching with
full screen hopefully my face is not
covering up too much oh this is where it
gets freaky okay if you're watching this
is part one your mind is about to get
weird
how do I get up there I have a box or
something can I get up here I can't
maybe I can jump from here okay it's
about to get weird so now everything is
mirrored so I hold left
for them to go right this is weird
so I am walking in air okay now what are
we supposed to do with these guys
there's a lever there okay so they both
need to stand on the lever
which we can adjust by that closes the
door okay that makes sense now I can
solve the puzzle all right so this guy
will keep walking now they should meet
in the middle
boom all right that's how it's done all
right we can keep going it should be
morning now but we're still inside so
it's dark
very eerie atmosphere in this game
there's a really strange story going on
I'm not sure I follow
it's really creepy as well I don't know
what's gonna happen next you never know
do you hear the heartbeat I hear a faint
heart very detailed game
we're gonna have to slide in gem maybe
we're a bit nervous see there's people
walking down there so I think we broke
free from whatever brainwash Oh God John
what is this Oh barely made it what is
this uncharted 4 I know that move better
than anyone
god I'm god I wish Nate's hair was here
these weekend
this isn't you mm god damn it I didn't
get scared come on get outta here okay
careful now
[ __ ] we're fine got a tiny heart attack
but gotta change pants later I think
we're okay though I hear people marching
don't get people what are they doing
they're being controlled by a hive mind
okay let's climb down here so they're
just dead bodies they must be well we're
gonna probably pretend that we blend in
I think I seen that in the trailer of
the game I always avoid trailers but
it's impossible not to see little snip
some pieces like I'm pulling off this
[ __ ] board nice and metaphor okay now
we can get in okay
these people know we escaped whoever's
controlling it
there are two Gatos should we get up
here looks like I can move the ladder
all right let's keep going
what is that thing looks like Wally a
giant ass Wally I love how it looks at
them there's perhaps a clue later he
tends to look at what you need to solve
the chemists mind I am this is an
elevator
it isn't have a price we can climb it
we can't grab
seems to be something about these two
let's go back and check out maybe
there's something I didn't see like this
there is definitely something with these
there's security though
Oh oh [ __ ] he got me right away oh my
god what that's creepy
all right I didn't thank God we did did
that in the right order I was meant to
be at least [ __ ] robots so creepy
can't tell this year this is supposed to
be it's like a it's kind of like a
modern modern it Nazi Germany happening
it feels like a modern 1980 situation
for a brief somehow oh god oh god get up
what do i do oh my god I think this was
supposed to happen get up get up get up
get up get out Oh God aah okay we're
walking ha ha ha
I knew this is gonna happen oh that
thing is suspicious of us aren't isn't
it
try to pay attention you I would so fail
at this
because it's really hard to walk in
rhythm
yeah think we're doing okay we're
expected to do a jump why
you got the rhythm man okay captain we
got a jump here nailed a some kind of
test too
get us
where these people are watching us why
are they watching what are they wearing
masks
oh my god and blinked on us but it
didn't
just got to turn around and turn back
again
around
turn back
whoo whoo that was close
camera actress I don't like it so Yuri
guess that's why they have the heartbeat
throat for us to get the rhythm okay I
think we're good for now
I could probably break for you now if
you would oh my god you hear that what
is that oh my god what's going to happen
how the dog will suppose that the dog is
gonna get us I'm glad it's dark because
I can't see what happened
it's okay part of a part of the game is
failing break free now I'm real nervous
I'm not gonna lie
go time to go time to go oh I hate the
dogs are scared so much oh my god hi
guys all the dog is still coming oh I
don't think I was run this way [ __ ] you
that's brutal
Jesus was I not fast enough
come on come on come on run run run run
am I supposed to make it the dog is too
fast oh I think I know how I got to make
it run down that way we'll lose time got
it
there's no way you would have gotten
that on the first try here we go now it
will run back up look away come on come
on oh I am Z ha ha ha so strange Hey
oh my god so she cool puzzle game with
me down yeah thank you oh thank you very
much
box you're coming with me because you
seem useful all right now he can come
with us but then again that won't work
wait oh god how do I do this if the box
needs to be there what if I just then
that won't do any
oh he can walk through
interesting
so if he will stand here perhaps we can
do something no he falls over what if he
puts us down here at least then we can
get up by herself and then we put the
box there okay got it
boom I thought he had to go through him
alright whatever a little tricky not
really
I solved it who cares okay now we came
out with our new little friend I'm
moonwalking right now guys
this is a Michael Jackson [ __ ] oh this
is weird okay interesting more puzzles
we might have to let's just check what's
over here first there's another
machinery and sleep
perhaps if we stop here we can climb but
it looks like it at least oh and this
guy can go up here as well okay I think
this is it
I just have to take this off now I need
to climb up they know but no option
- another here let's try it you know
what it's crazy but what happens what
happens if you double up
what haha okay now we sweet euphoria
alright so there we go
and now we have to take ourself off here
oh and now we jump up again whoa this is
a very strange puzzle but I love it now
we can go through oh my god that's so
cool
alright keep going forward construction
people down there are they also control
I don't know
now we're going to go up here and pull
the lever seems to open something
yeah they're real people some good
freaked out with us I think I was
supposed to fire fall down the hall
oh I got hit by it I got hit by it and
ice tide that is a very detailed game
that they did that that's pretty cool
actually like I don't even mind that I
died that's pretty [ __ ] cool hahaha
alright let's just wait for the whole
[ __ ] thing I'm so impatient I am so
sorry
there we go now we call in the water and
we're safe and sound now how we knew
there was water there I don't know I
have this urge to swim this way I don't
know why let's see what if we got over
here something under the water maybe
nope
okay well let's swim this way
oh my god I love playing this I really
do it's just because it's it's kind of
like it's weird to compare them because
they're so different means but uncharted
for the game is just so well paced like
I know I will won't have to cut these
episodes and I think that really shows
that it's a good game because they
thought about exactly how the game is
going to play out
and I really enjoy that um and just as I
said that I got stuck alright oh there's
something here let's go up my
controllers shaking so I get the feeling
I'm gonna run out of air okay yeah this
is it describe this there we go hurry up
hurry up hurry up okay so now we have
this floating I mean there's light here
so there has to be better but I don't
think we can reach it maybe we can climb
the vents thing let's try it
we're here anyway
nobody reminds me when you had a boat a
little sailing boat in limbo do you
remember that oh but I love that part ha
ha okay well let's go over here surely
this is where we're supposed to go right
right tumble right
I feel like I'm missing something
okay we can go up here we're probably
gonna put some box or something on the
on our Lowell no we're just that was it
okay hey I'll take it a button means you
have to press it we going up or down oh
do we empty the water I have a feeling
we should not press this button yet cuz
we didn't know what that button does man
although it's our only way to progress
okay
did I make it come on so incensed when
something what are you doing it's a what
what was I not fast enough we can go
here now okay weird a hatch listen guys
I know I'm not the smartest I know I'm
the handsomest I'm just kidding I'm
neither so I'm sorry if I get stuck at
things that might be obvious I know
that's gonna happen
now the door should open we need old
what is the goal here what if we press
the water now that might be it
we just have to make it here okay that
wasn't too difficult sometimes the
easiest solution
the simplest solutions to write one well
what's happening here
hello
what has happened I can't see anything I
can pull this though why oh I'm taking
this with me and I think I have to push
down this is a coffin or some [ __ ] I'm
so intrigued by their universe I love
how we're just playing a puzzle game but
we're so distracted by it all everything
around it it's such a great way okay
the puzzle isn't done yet we have to go
up on that chain there
yes he recants
[ __ ] yeah we did it whoa so smart what
is happening up there is that a train
god I hate being chase in this game
all right that's a lot of people let's
not get caught by the eye it literally
looks like an iris - okay let's follow
its movements there's some there's oh no
down down down down down down down down
down oh my god it oh it moves of course
of course
oh this is goddamn making me tense man I
don't think we're gonna make it this
round next one next one breath come on
come on come on yeah hi guys
just hanging around cool oh my god it
keeps going I'm gonna have to end this
episode here I love this game I hope
you're enjoying it as much as I am and
if you do please go ahead and leave it
like and I'll see you tomorrow with
another episode I promise and as always
stay awesome press I can't I can't
believe it I can't
Oh
he keeps happening
I'm crying it's so beautiful